yeah welcome to this video 15 minute
game playing some person here from
Germany no goons block don't know him
has also got the known name and then the
notes ok start d5 and then play play
solid set up for a change let's see em
aha b3 yeah this is some move on it very
often leading to to the reti opening and
can normally why plays Bishop be tuned
because this is supposed to be M quite
ok for black getting active play along
this diagonal with c5 let them show that
day I should play see pfeiffer
immediately maybe I'm start with done 97
and then play c5 maybe on the next month
or after castling the idea anyways to
make use of this diagonal bishop is
happiness actually the reason why the
smooth order isn't um so popular but it
seems to have caught him by surprise
anyway
it's also possible in fact them to not
play c5 and play Knight to c6
pressurizing on the default porn just
with pieces but I like to place your
father useless pawn unknown you want to
get better development this is
interesting this looks on quite strange
to me if I take our night g5 then on
this night looks really exposed on g5
and that's so let's do this it's um
probably not not a tactical mistake but
wait wait wait wait wait let's just
think about this briefly if I take on c4
and place c5 isn't a sir isn't this good
maybe Queen a5 check is as tempting I
take on c4 move the night he will play
an idea three back and I don't really
don't really gain anything with that c5
immediately is also move okay that's uh
not spend too much time this is probably
am fine for black anyway but not not so
terrible for why that investing more
time will net me a big edge or something
Bishop g5 um I was really unconventional
so I'm what's going on now if M if Jose
III which looks like the normal move gap
lai knight c6 center increase the
pressure on this pawn probably their
needs to retreat on the instantly
retreats so um if i take he takes mmm
yeah i just have a good structure after
this the only problem can be than the
bishop on c8 just castle and play knight
c6 neck smooth and get the bishop on c8
but it seems that down i might be able
to even play you 65 and just develop
this piece I've got 96 coming
the outcome probably won't take so this
primo firm is probably not really coming
up going to see three maybe okay he took
so I wasn't really am expecting this so
um b6 should I play b6 stop this pawn he
can play 95 but it's really not not
getting him anywhere there should be
seven I think I should use this pawn to
to cover a c5 so that he cannot play
pawn to c5 himself the next move some
might be Bishop a six and Roxy aid
putting more pressure on on the pawn
Knight if I have just Bishop d7 well no
it's not okay okay then I go Keyshia
basics
he can play 9 p-5 of course may be the
way to go and then probably just took a
to c eight ER 97's sorry so thread get
this night on b5 let's of course some
some annoying peace always am
threatening the a7 pond and tonight to
d6 sounds also a possibility so he's got
some activity for this week's e4 pawn
Adam it shouldn't really be enough but
it's not not easy for me to to make some
headway at least them at the moment it
seems it seems like this let's say let's
say I would exchange on deewana if I
exchanged on the one rook t8 maybe takes
on the eight ninety eight nine eight
seven Bishop takes some c4 and then
there's a 2 and H weighing so winning a
pawn actually maybe this some yeah come
on let's let's do that exchanging
here should should be beneficial if he
doesn't exchange maybe I should have
considered this a bit more maybe can
what I what I believe but I'm just
looking at is if he takes and place
nitey 549 to deform this I didn't really
take into account hmm yeah this could be
it could be a possibility hmm yeah
probably this wasn't i wasn't the best
way to play it after move like em night
295 it's not even clear if I if I can
avoid to capture on b5 hmm I can play f6
am the night it's 97 an option look so
we had to put the night on d 7 but maybe
fearne I'd be eight coming hmm 95 f 6
you can also go to g3 intending night
before yeah a7 is simply hanging I mean
this means that I maybe need to take
which isn't necessarily a terrible I
mean it just means that I don't have any
kind of advantage
yeah yeah the the fun question is what
about f6 nom 97's is really coming and
we are probably a 93 I'm not sure I have
something better cannot tolerate the
night on only 5'4 long cannot move
pieces at some point it just takes a 7
so probably need to do that I've even
had on the clock this is rare and yeah
what am I supposed to do now i can i can
just take b5 I mean it's not not a very
attractive looking move but the
alternative would be just plain night so
c 6 this is this is the better i think i
don't need to take immediately i can
think about now now i may be threatening
to take and play 90 for attacking be 582
so i'm winning a pawn in this side this
way or even though or maybe maybe if i
were to take now they take now on b5
yeah the problem is he some may be
planning to to play a pawn to c5 also
which would help him to get rid of the
weakness not sure if I have to I have
some way to to prevent this now probably
not i mean c5 don't really see a way to
to to continue here c5 justice also says
problems
maybe I can try and try this but it's
it's petrosky IDM if it takes on b5 with
the a pawn Knight d4 be 32 c 5 try to
put pants on dark square so that is
bishop is a potential problem but it's a
very weak this is a bit risky even maybe
right before to see 6s I'm as a possible
problem so not sure this was really good
but okay I want to try at least them to
do something it's maybe not really
justified then cut them get again tricky
later yeah II to a plane I'd be three
blocking c5 this was the main idea that
he cannot place you five he of course
could have taken with the with the sea
porn instead of the April oh but I
figured you would take with the upon any
waits the more logical move in any case
yeah the question is night before to see
success this may be may be a problem for
me my idea aside to play now night cat6
attacking the spawn and it cannot
advance at the moment so maybe a uh-huh
hmm not sure let's let's go go to the
seven the square F or was prevent is
preventing e5 still it surprised me
authority there were more pressing
things to do but okay 96 I'm taking the
pawn it's not so easy to react to that
okay he wants to to try and counter tech
but hmm the pony 7 at the moment is Sir
is covered so if i play if i play now 92
he plays what Bishop f1 yeah then I take
96 Nazi 694 then then III is saying was
check yeah maybe I'm quick enough to to
emerge with an extra pond here it's
possible so 92 Bishop f1 takes on f1
king of 196
50 plays knight c6 94-98 793 check kingi
295 and on d5 I'm covering them covering
be sexier this is a pawn okay so let's
go for this so take and night to d6 yeah
on knight c6 94 kingi to if he covers
instead then I just go back yeah but he
can then take him this is the problem
yes still-still um no no no no no no
there there is there's a bit of
something here because of my better
coordination 96-97 I'm just threatening
to approach the night and wouldn't be to
be five porn maybe it's nothing but I
won't won't accept a draw quickly here
ok this I need to do on King d3 i've got
a five we are then you can play ok let's
let's let's continue of it what I'm
is that his night is tied to the b5 porn
probably is you might have some defense
of course but it's tied to to the b5
pawn and what I'm trying to do is just
plain owie five this some blocks is king
so it cannot play come up like King
before or something and now my idea is
to to activate the King king is 65 and
I'm somewhat quicker I can also try to
approach this night maybe you for no
yeah but he fights and it's not a move
you like to make and now let's see let's
see what happens it's not it's not
completely clear cut here at least I
think white is so the only one with
losing chances okay so hmm taking if I'm
letting before if it takes if I was
checked out I need to I need together
not quite sure what what is the point of
96 if he now needs to return then this
was wasn't really doing much no kinky
five here
not sure what what's the big idea I
think this just lost tossed I'm young
since this isn't something now something
real cannot move the night if you move
the King up late Qing Yi form and of
course he's got some moves on the
kingside Adam do they really help i also
just threaten let's say hmm so not sure
I can I grew I can also play e4e
forecheck King c3 King c5 and I'll just
win this pawn I don't see anything great
the Dwight can white can try to do I can
also play King c5 instantly not gonna
form but you follow sir looks good
really also I could move from King side
pawns but this looks like a simple
solution I'm not sure that moving pawns
here is a good thing as and so the night
might go over to the kingside entered
text pawns and I think they are less
likely to get attacked on the initial
square so then then on them and then on
GF I for example so on let's just take
this so on I want to pawn after all
maybe I should have taken with the King
actually I should have given this at
least some thought okay but anyway so
this night on d6
kavos f5 so it cannot do night at five
and i can just improve the position
further advancing the beep on and yeah
it's that some threat I don't know let's
let's push the beep on not lose too much
time it's probably right anyway some
idea maybe each six of some idea but I
can I can just take it everything feels
don't really see a the counter play
maybe yeah I'm overlooking something
so I thought just go over to hu and then
push this B 3 mp3 is not the not so
precise
95 I can try can you to grab this so one
what is this counterplay can try to
attack the edge porn but if you move
through the night I would just attack it
oh wait let's just think briefly night
to f7 some possibility I doubt it don't
really want to want to go down come on
let's um get this get this rolling apart
passed pawns must be pushed the famous
old rule y-yeah the beep on just
promotes with help of the night I've got
that night c4 so it's a possibility yeah
I think when I even offered the draw I
mean around here it is simply somewhat
easier for black to play maybe what can
draw with precise play with its own it's
not not an easy easy thing to do I mean
it's just I think 96 year was helpful of
course this just lost moves maybe he
needs to go reform it's possible just
getting the square so I can't go to d5 i
mean this this really loses time and
gives me a huge space advantage here
here i'm already winning a pawn I mean
this is just he needs to play he for
right he needs to play your form or
maybe he has time for one move um let's
say I don't know h3y oh man not a move
that helps you but some 0 move and then
he for after King g6
yeah maybe force the most
straightforward hard to see how you
would play without this and yet so it's
probably already winning yeah yeah
thanks for watching pretty interesting
endgame I think I think I should have
played somewhat better on move 20 or
something around here this looked like I
should get something but maybe not be
five is still ok yeah thanks for
watching